good morning great it is good morning
it's not raining my name is ray lane and
I am chairman of the board of trustees
of Carnegie Mellon University I'm very
pleased to welcome all of you especially
those that are on the web including
students and friends from Silicon Valley
and Qatar and other locations all around
the world i'm also pleased to recognize
pennsylvania state representative dan
Frankel dan were I had a chance to meet
you yet but you're somewhere but it says
you're here as well as age to
Pennsylvania State Senator Jay Costa and
councilman Bill Rizzuto well it's a
great day we're here to celebrate this
remarkable research university and we
are here to celebrate and honor a great
American philanthropist is my privilege
and it is certainly my honor today to
announce some wonderful news william s
dietrich although we call him uncle bill
uncle bill
me
good
where is it bill there's a little
cheering section out here it just loves
you right uncle bill bill a long time
trustee and great friend of the
University a man with a lifetime of
committed service to this city has
announced that he has made plans to
provide a gift of 265 million dollar
fund to support Carnegie Mellon
let me say it again just to confirm that
you heard me correctly 265 million
dollars this is this is the largest gift
an individual from an individual in the
university's history in fact it is one
of the top 10 most generous gifts ever
made to an American University by an
individual
personally I want to say it has been at
the light to serve Carnegie Mellon
alongside bill Diedrich on the board of
trustees it was no surprise to me to
learn that bill had structured this gift
with characteristic thoughtfulness and
care its purpose is wide-ranging and it
will provide great flexibility to
allocate these funds campus-wide to
areas of emerging opportunity and
greatest need it is a gift for the
entire institution I have to say I feel
it feels a bit ironic to me that just
last week a pretty slow week just before
labor days I received a new book sent to
me authored by Bill and today I have the
honor to announce this great gift and
speak of the respect I have for this man
now I'm a I'm an odd duck a lot of
people would agree with that statement
but I'm odd because i live in Silicon
Valley and I love Pittsburgh in fact I
love Pittsburgh more than silicon valley
so when I get a book called eminent
pittsburghers I don't just set it aside
and say well I'll get to it sometime I
open it to see if I'm listed as one of
them and to my disappointment bill bill
only wrote about long gone dead
pittsburghers but great men whom
everybody in Pittsburgh today owes a
debt of gratitude to because they gave
back and did it in a way that continues
to enrich Pittsburgh throughout
generations bill wrote in this book and
I quote the 40 year period from 1872
1910 marks Pittsburgh's Golden Age
favorable geography unique natural
resources and a super abundance of
entrepreneurial talent lifted Pittsburgh
to a position of national and
international prominence never seen
before or since Pittsburgh was seething
a seething cauldron of entrepreneurial
activity end quote sounds like Silicon
Valley imagine a period of time when
Andrew Carnegie the melons george
westinghouse henry clay frick and henry
hines all walked the streets of
Pittsburgh had it not been for the
generosity of those successful
entrepreneurs Pittsburgh today would be
a mere shadow of itself today we're
witnessing repeated history repeated as
we are the ones that can claim to know
bill Dietrich another great entrepreneur
who walked the streets of Pittsburgh
and just like those kings of our golden
era bill now rekindles the sustaining
greatness of our city and his generosity
will ensure the education of future
generations Bill's announcement today is
all about the future of Pittsburgh it's
an incredible investment in American
research and in our youth it is also
crucially important in the final years
of Carnegie Mellon's inspire innovation
campaign and we hope and expect that
bill's generosity will be very very
contagious as we continue the campaign
to its completion in 2013 this kind of
generosity is an enormous vote of
confidence in the University it is
confidence built on Carnegie Mellon's
amazing and rapid rise to the front
ranks of global research universities
over the past few decades it's a
confidence built on bills conviction
that higher education has never been
more important to us all and that
knowledge and human creativity are
limitless resources that can and will
shape our collective future bills gift
is also confidence in the leadership of
this university and particularly the
leadership of Jerry Cohen as we all know
Jerry is a remarkable man his enthusiasm
for this university seems to grow
stronger every year Jerry's intellectual
curiosity his humility his abiding
respect for his faculty colleagues and
his engagement with students all
convinced me that Carnegie Mellon has it
its helm one of the great leaders of the
world of higher education today join me
join me in welcoming the 8th president
of Carnegie Mellon Jerry Cohen
thank you thank you Ray and thank you
Bill thank you thank you thank you this
is truly a very proud and historic day
for Carnegie Mellon bill Dietrich has
now joined the ranks of the great
patrons of American higher education
most of you here know him and know him
as a western Pennsylvania native the man
who's had a remarkable career as an
entrepreneur in the steel industry and
then as an investor and a money manager
bill is very proud of Pittsburgh and
proud to be a pittsburgher and he's
focused his energy his leadership and
his generosity on many organizations and
institutions in our city and fortunately
for us Carnegie Mellon has long been one
of them working with Bill as a trustee
in listening to his counsel has been one
of the pleasures and highlights of my
time as president his strong opinions
and if you know bill you know he has
strong opinions and his leadership have
made our board in our University a
better place in many many ways thank you
Bill for all that you've done for
Carnegie Mellon and especially for this
phenomenal gift
we're going to be using the word
historic many times today and it's a
word that is apt in this case this gift
is truly historic that's not just talk
even taking to account the time value of
money this gift is larger than the one
Andrew Carnegie made in establishing
this university in nineteen
and the gift will have elastic impact in
the way the melon family's generosity
has had on this university over many
many decades indeed Bill's gift is
perpetual and its impact will grow over
time words like phenomenal magnificent
and every other super love you can think
of are completely apt on this day
philanthropists like Carnegie the melons
and now bill Dietrich are people who get
excited about ideas people who care
about knowledge creation and education
they share this University's commitment
in many ways and in particular by
investing in an area or a Carnegie
Mellon can make a difference over the
years these people have helped to set
wonderful things in motion including
major achievements in computer science
in engineering in the Natural Sciences
in business and the social sciences in
public policy and in the arts and the
humanities things that have changed the
world and added new dimensions to the
university strengths and capacities
Carnegie Mellon has a quality of is rare
in higher education it's hard to pin
down but one of the our graduates Thomas
Cooley who went on to become Dean of its
Stern School of Business at New York
University put it this way Carnegie
Mellon's is a culture of serious inquiry
a place it emphasizes theory and
evidence rather than anecdote Carnegie
Mellon is a place that encourages
thinking that transcends conventional
wisdom and the boundaries of disciplines
it's a culture that's characterized by a
preference for solving problems
collaboratively and determined ambition
to take on difficult and meaningful
challenges challenges that once met
change the way the world
lives and works that's Carnegie Mellon
like bill we are proud to be
Pittsburghers and to be a Pittsburgh
institution our distinctive culture has
its roots here and is reflective of our
hometown we share Pittsburgh's lack of
boastful pretension although I have to
admit we are boasting a little bit today
but it's back to self-assess
self-effacement tomorrow full time we
believe that success comes from hard
work and a lot of patient effort just
the way pittsburgh in pittsburgh errs do
ray mentioned that that bill is designed
this gift so that benefits the entire
university and that is indeed true this
is especially valuable to a place like
Carnegie Mellon where the ability to
respond quickly and nimbly to unexpected
opportunity is critical to our success
this has never been more important than
it is now as the rate of change in
science and technology and in society
continues to accelerate every advance
and new knowledge alters the research
and education agenda in ways that we
can't predict it's even altering the way
we conceive a research itself
a flexible and generous endowment gift
like bills will allow Carnegie Mellon to
follow new lines of inquiry open up by
this pace of change it will help us to
recruit brilliant young faculty to build
an innovative lab or studio and almost
certainly it will help us to advise
whole new fields of study something we
have done many times in the past I don't
think any of us can fully imagine when
amazing directions science and
technology or the Arts will be pursuing
a decade from now nor can we envision
the full impact of this gift but we can
have confidence that Carnegie Mellon
people will be setting the pace because
bill gift will make it possible while
bills gift will benefit the entire
university a significant portion of it
will be used to support the humanities
and Social Sciences in recognition of
this in a bills extraordinary generosity
we ask bill if we could rename H and SS
in his honor he agreed but he asks that
we name the college not for himself but
in the memory of his beloved mother this
is truly in the tradition of Andrew
Carnegie who as you may know named a
college at the university in honor of
his mother margaret morrison Carnegie I
am extremely pleased to announce that
the college will henceforth be known as
the Mariana Brown Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences
the naming of a college is a momentous
occasion in the life of any university
in fact one that we will celebrate later
today with the students in the Faculty
of the new Dietrich college but let me
underscore now that for Carnegie Mellon
the naming of the of its humanities and
Social Sciences College is especially
significant it represents a statement
about the progress that H and SS has
made over the last several years and
especially under the leadership of Dean
John lajas key
it's also a statement about Carnegie
Mellon's commitment to the future of the
humanities and Social Sciences at this
university to commemorate this new name
we've created a plaque and I'm going to
be assisted by two students who are
going to get up right now there they are
this is andres villas a sophomore in
economics and Medini anna vahala a
senior in sutton the science and
humanities scholars program if you will
unveil the plaque voila
this plaque will be installed in the
entrance lobby of Baker hall the
historic building that houses the
college a wonderful portrait of Andrew
Carnegie already hangs there as does
another plaque honoring our first
president Arthur Hamish log this is the
plaque that students rub the nose of for
a good luck before exams bills plaque
will take its place they're marking this
as a historic day in the life of the
University this is a great and wonderful
day for Carnegie Mellon and I thank bill
Dietrich from the bottom of my heart on
behalf of the entire university
community ladies and gentlemen I'm very
pleased and honored to present to you
our guest of honor our great donor our
great supporter bill Dietrich bill
I like to thank everyone for joining us
on a great day for Carnegie Mellon
University is wonderful to share this
occasion with so many of my friends but
this day is not about bill Dietrich it's
about my mother mary anna Brown and it's
about western Pennsylvania and Carnegie
Mellon my mother mary anna Brown was
born in cherry tree Pennsylvania a town
so small you can't find it on the map
today her father dr. David a brown moved
to Greenville Pennsylvania when Marianna
was a young girl in Greenville he was an
eye ear nose and throat doctor and
practiced for 50 years my father was
also from Greenville and married my
mother shortly after they both graduated
from t.o College mom died in March of
1983 one week before her 50th wedding
anniversary dad to his everlasting
credit told me countless times that the
best decision he ever made was to marry
my mother my mother's life centered
around her family and her unconditional
love for her family this is a notion
somewhat out of date today it worked for
her in the early 60s when my father was
attempting to make a financial come back
a lot of his work was done from home in
the morning my mother would deliver the
first breakfast at seven-thirty by 8 30
eggs would be stone cold and a fresh
breakfast was put on the coffee table it
would sometimes take three breakfasts to
get through the morning mum logged a lot
of time in the principal's office on
damage control duties
one of my more notable exploits was
setting off a firecracker in a pencil
sharpener the air the air was fogged
with pencil shavings pulling my bacon
out of the fire and the pencil sharpener
escapade was one of my mother's finest
hours Marianna Brown Dietrich was no
Tiger mother the happiness of our little
family my father my sister and myself
took precedence over all else I don't
mean to describe our family as an early
version of Ozzie and Harriet Nelson it
was not our family was male-dominated I
remember as a young boy being packed off
to sunday school at the point of a gun I
raised a logical question with mom why
is dad out playing golf every Sunday
when I'm going to Sunday school the
mom's answer delhi when he was your age
he loved to go to Sunday school I had my
doubts growing up in rural Conneaut Lake
Pennsylvania the Boy Scouts played an
important part in my life and as a side
note conneaut lake is three-quarters of
a mile wide and three miles long and is
in that the largest natural lake in the
state of Pennsylvania which tells you
Pennsylvania is not the land of 10,000
lakes to get my boy scout merit badge I
had to take apart the trap under a sink
to repair the botched plumbing job mom
had to call in a plumber I was an Eagle
Scout and attended the third national
jamboree in orange county california in
1953 in the 8th international Jamboree
at Niagara on the Lake Ontario in 1955
when time came for college it was a
simple process SI t test one time in
February of my senior year and that was
it I applied to three colleges allegheny
William and Mary and Princeton but the
decision had already been made in my
senior year I was looking for an article
in the world book encyclopedia when they
had encyclopedias which was arranged
alphabetically it was in the Peace
section and it happened to have an
article on Princeton underneath a
picture of Blair arch in the article the
article began Princeton has sent more
Road scholars to Oxford than any other
American University I never bothered to
read the rest of the article hell I
didn't even know Princeton was in New
Jersey my parents were both opposed to
my going to Princeton for different
reasons but put up a united front
William and Mary was there substitute
but just a year before I applied to
Princeton
in 1955 the wig Clea soffit society
invited convicted perjurer Alger Hiss to
speak during the age of Joe McCarthy
this created a national furor dad's vm
response I don't want my boy going to a
damn commie school i believe it was my
mother that got me into Princeton to
attorneys came down to conneaut lake
from Erie Pennsylvania to interview me
they began by announcing my parents alma
mater as feel college and not till
College she was too polite to correct
them afterwards she allowed us how she
thought they were a little stuffy they
thought she was charming my mother's
opposition was based not on politics but
on my future happiness she thought it
was a big jump from Connie at lake high
school she was right I couldn't get into
Princeton today and certainly couldn't
get into Carnegie Mellon with my
marginal mass kills I'm sure I'm the
only person on this university campus
today who does not know how to use a
personal computer I'm a hundred percent
computer illiterate a few words on my
own career in this light I'm reminded of
a speech by Winston Churchill it seems
there's an appropriate Churchillian
quote for almost every occasion
referring to clement attlee who
succeeded him as prime minister in 1945
Churchill remarked he is a modest man
who has much to be modest about my
business career in steel and then in
construction products was a long slow
slog the company almost went bankrupt in
1975 losing over half its net worth in
15 months who was tough on me but it was
tougher on my father he was fully
retired and living in Florida I remember
his anxious phone calls son are we going
to make it I said don't worry dad we're
going to make it the truth be known I
wasn't sure as a Duke of Wellington said
after Waterloo it was a near thing the
soon after our brush with bankruptcy we
begin to produce a product called light
metal framing commonly known as steel
studs we made a couple of good decisions
it had more than our share of good luck
company managed to capture forty percent
of the national market for this product
Mike Campbell a character in Ernest
Hemingway's The Sun Also Rises faced
bankruptcy the protagonist of the novel
Jake Barnes asked how it happened
Campbell replied laconically slowly at
first rapidly toward the end our
situation was the reverse our fortunes
improved slowly at first and then
rapidly ater on I said this day is about
this region and this city it had long
been my dream to have a foundation to
benefit the greater pittsburgh area my
daughter anne elizabeth dietrich who is
here with us today was supportive of the
project right from the start before we
had much money in the kitty the die was
cast when Dietrich industries was sold
in 1996 and all the proceeds passed to a
charitable annuity trust at the age of
58 i launched into a new career as a
chief investment officer i made more
than my share of rookie mistakes but
learn gradually the way things have
worked out we have built something that
will have an enduring impact on this
region I also said that this day is
about Carnegie Mellon pittsburgh has
many wonderful institutions which enrich
our lives but carnegie mellon university
has a special place on this list for me
i always valued education and never stop
learning and it's hard not to be aware
of what goes on at this campus this
university puts pittsburgh on anybody's
world map of great research cities bring
people come here as students and faculty
and their presence in our community add
something extraordinary the firm
attracts companies like google the
college attracts some firms like Google
and Intel they create new companies and
new ideas they add to the city's vibrant
artistic and cultural life they win
Tony's Oscars and Nobel prizes they
never stop exploring they never stopped
looking for a better way to do something
and they never stopped working to make
tomorrow better things better tomorrow
than they are today we are all grateful
to Jerry Cohen and his predecessors for
their extraordinary leadership in
building and sustaining this great
University and I feel privileged to be
able to contribute to its future I have
no doubt that as brian has the past has
been its best days lie ahead my mother
would be thrilled to have her name
associated with this wonderful school
and my hope is that name this college
for her you remember some of the values
that made her life so meaningful I note
that we customarily refer to our
undergraduate University as our alma
mater our mothers school there is wisdom
in that idea sometimes in the drive to
compete and strive and struggle we
forget and underpinning all our
achievement and accomplishment is a
simple sense of being loved is that
feeling of security that allows us to
take the risks dream the dream and dare
to live life with a courage that is
forward by chirring and abiding care
with marianna brown dietrich college we
will now have a constant reminder of
this wisdom when i think of my mother
today i'm reminded of a notable american
classic in 1941 book by photojournalist
walker evans and film critic novelist
James Agee called let us now praise
famous men it is about southern
sharecroppers who had little in material
wealth but were rich in the solid values
of honesty hard work and unwavering
commitment to family by the standards of
that book my mother was a famous person
thank you for being here
thank you so much bill those words were
truly inspiring to all of us I think
good morning everyone my name is Aaron
gross and I am a very recent alum of the
now renamed Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences H&S s is
very very glad to finally have a name to
be given to us so we're very we're very
pleased today it's it's really an honor
and a privilege to be here today on this
truly special occasion to share with you
all a few thoughts about the history and
significance of the fence which is so
beautifully painted in honor of Bill
right outside this tent students and and
many people in the audience will already
know a bit about the history of the
fence and they'll know that the fence is
one of the great cherished traditions of
Carnegie Mellon back in the days when
Carnegie Mellon was just the Carnegie
technical schools the ground that we're
sitting on right now was not flat as it
is right now but was actually a true cut
a ravine that separated the Carnegie
technical schools on one side from the
margaret morrison college for women on
the other side and over this big cut
there was a bridge that served to
connect the two areas and that bridge
served as a very convenient mixing and
mingling point for the men of Carnegie
Tech to interact with the the women of
Maggie mo but over time as Carnegie Tech
grew the space where the cut was was
gradually filled in by construction and
it became the solid ground that were
sitting on today and naturally that that
bridge that had been there before was
useless and it was taken down in its
place I believe it was the senior class
of the year nineteen twenty-three
erected offense to serve as a similar
meeting point between students and a
gathering point on campus and the legend
goes that one night a group of
enterprising young fraternity brothers
decided that they would paint the fence
in honor of a party that they were
having and the story is that that party
went on to become the most successful
party that Carnegie Mellon has ever seen
and probably ever will see and
ever since that day students from
literally generations of carnegie-mellon
students have painted the fence to
advertise their club meetings campus
events political affiliations
remembrances there have even been a few
wedding proposals that have been made
via the fence so truly a great
communication medium on campus but more
than the fence just being a great way to
communicate the fence has become a place
that truly connects the campus community
you can ask any student of any major any
department and they'll be able to tell
you about a time that they were out at
midnight painting the fence with their
friends with only hand brushes those are
the rules no rollers no spray paint and
only between 12 and 6 the fence is truly
the single most recognizable most
cherished and most valued symbol of
Carnegie Mellon and it's in that spirit
that i'm going to ask andres and made a
need to come back up to present a gift
on behalf of the student body to you
bill in honor of your incredible
generosity today so if you will reveal
the replica
this is a replica of the fence I believe
it weighs I was told that it weighs 30
pounds so i will not be transporting
that thank you again bill thank you so
much
I'd like now to introduce ed Frank and
Sarah rachie were both graduates and
strong advocates for carnegie mellon
university as well as my neighbors in
Silicon Valley Sarah studied visual art
at the College of Fine Arts and Ned did
his doctorate in computer science
Sarah's an artist and EDD is now in a
Silicon Valley executive and a life
trustee of Carnegie Mellon he is also
chair of the university's 1 billion
dollar fund raising campaign one of
their daughters whippin is also a CMU
graduate with a degree in drama and
creative writing let me introduce ed and
Sarah
thank you Ray and good morning to all of
you and thank you array I also want to
let you know that I did talk to Bill I
know how you can get in the second
edition of the book okay it could it
could cost you a little bit but don't
worry about it okay it's a great
pleasure to be here today for this
exciting occasion and like all of you to
thank bill on behalf of all of us who
are graduates of Carnegie Mellon for
this wonderful gift bill what you have
done is made possible truly a
transformational future for the
university not to mention making my job
is ahead of the capital campaign a heck
of a lot easier in this era of
globalization where the preeminence of
the United States is being challenged in
many ways there's one area where without
question we remain preeminent and that's
our research universities Carnegie
Mellon is part of a unique group of
American institutions that are
responsible for producing the
preponderance of the world's most
brilliant engineers and scientists not
to mention many of the world's great
actors architects and artists and in
doing so we help make the world a better
place the underpinning of all of this is
something else that the u.s. excels in
and that's philanthropy the great
educational and cultural institutions of
our country almost without exception by
the result of the wisdom public
mindedness envisioned of men and women
of means and while Carnegie Mellon is a
university like no other it simply would
not exist without people like pill
people of great foresight who thoroughly
understand the value of University of
sections hours in making our economy
more productive our communities more
vital our country stronger and the world
more just and secure in making the gift
we're announcing today build egret
firmly places himself among the
philanthropic giants of our time
but I'm sure bill would agree that while
he is fortunate to be able to make such
a gift every gift no matter what the
size makes an important difference in
furthering our University's mission when
our board of trustees of which bill has
been an integral part for many many
years established the inspire innovation
campaign roughly eight years ago we knew
we would have to work hard to reach our
goal I don't know if bill had in mind at
the time a gift of the magnitude of the
one he's making today but I do know he
was always committed to making the
campaign successful because of its
importance to the future of Carnegie
Mellon I also know that in making this
gift bill is looking for many others
hopefully many of you both graduates and
future graduates to follow in his
footsteps in committing themselves to
Carnegie Mellon into providing our
university with the resources it needs
to attract and train the best students
in the world bill just spoke eloquently
about his family life I was great and
especially how his mother taught him to
recognize the depth of responsibility we
have to one another this shared
responsibility is something that is
conveniently ignored by almost all of us
at various points in our lives but we
can learn a lesson from Bill's mother
who was not wealthy famous or powerful
but nevertheless did what she could for
her family in her community with the
resources she had and it was the joy of
her life to do so this is dietrich score
conviction that we have a shared
responsible to our shared responsibility
to our community is what philanthropy
and great philanthropy is all about bill
in making your gift you inspire all of
us to do our part and taking
responsibility for the institutions that
make our community and our country great
thank you so much for your generosity
they've now like
you
now like to ask my wife Sarah to come up
who give her some of her thoughts on the
bills gift to the University hello it's
lovely to see all the alumni and
graduates and students here I was a
student here once and I really enjoyed
my time here and appreciated my
professors and i want to add my
gratitude and delight at bill's
generosity as ray told you ed came to
Carnegie Mellon as a doctoral student in
computer science while I came to study
art and what seems like a few short
years later our daughter wit and studied
drama and writing two generations of our
family now represent different ways that
Carnegie Mellon has and will influence
the world I can only imagine the ways in
which bills gift will have impact on our
world it will build labs studios and
classrooms it will allow our students to
dream and theorize and write to produce
plays paintings concertos poems and
tutoring software it will build a lot of
very interesting robots it will fuel
inspiration and results towards reducing
carbon emissions and designing buildings
that produce more energy than they
consume this gift would contribute to
efforts to make sure that everyone has
access to clean air and clean water and
these are very difficult problems
Carnegie Mellon students and graduates
will unravel the mysteries of our brains
and our behavior they will help us to
learn new languages professors and
students will mesh science and art to
visualize and model the origins of the
universe from that knowledge and scholar
ship they will create new materials and
helped propel human beings into the
cosmos most of all it will enable the
University to continue its mission to
teach to explore creativity in all
endeavors this generous gift will ensure
that many generations of dynamic
informed an innovative Carnegie Mellon
graduates will create the future thank
you so much bill
and I don't know who's speaking next
sorry I'm always a good default Thank
You Edd and thank you Sarah for those
inspiring reflections and all you do for
Carnegie Mellon it's amazing we have a
scrum of about five of us in Northern
California a few of us in Southern
California and we talked a lot about
Carnegie Mellon and they may you know
all of our cohorts may be surprised to
hear us talk about Carnegie Mellon but
they're more surprised we're not talking
about Stanford and we don't talk about
Stanford I also want to thank Ian Mac
itarsi hear it Ian thank you i want to
thank you and the delts for staying up
all night painting that fence thank you
I hope you keep that quiet I actually
thanked Adele for anything okay good as
a kappa sig now i want to assure all of
you that this party is just getting
started there will be a celebration for
the students and faculty of the Mariana
brown Dietrich college this afternoon at
Baker hall and the party continues
tonight for everyone in the Carnegie
Mellon community with a free concert on
the mall featuring the rock band Guster
yeah and then fireworks after that so
it's yeah nice huh yeah what I want to
see I want to see low-hanging clouds
with fireworks going up through them
that's what so whether you're here in
person for all of these events today or
you're watching in Pittsburgh or your
some other location around the world on
behalf of Bill Dietrich Jerry Cohen the
board of trustees and the entire
university community I want to thank all
of you for joining us today for this
historic occasion and we celebrate and
honor our very generous friend Bill
Diedrich in the future of this great
University Carnegie Mellon thank you
you